hello everyone if you by any chance run
into Anatoly Karpov today feel free to
stop him and congratulate him I rather
wish him a happy birthday as today is
his birthday and that's why I put a car
pool over here I thought it would be a
nice touch for today's video I was
planning to do it in my previous video
but you know I forgot but here we have
another another game from around 11:00
of the 2013 candidates tournament it's
Alexander Grisha versus Magnus Carlsen
so before we check out some photos from
this round we do we do have the
standings at around 10 so Carlsen is in
first place with 7 points and the grid
shook four and a half points so I
wouldn't for Greece show here with the
white pieces would bring him over to
five and a half and could maybe still
maybe he could still join the race for
first place in this tournament but you
know it's a long shot but either way
you're playing against Magnus Cross and
the highest rated player in the world
you want to win this game definitely so
as usual let's check out some force and
we do have quite a lot of photos from
this round here we have a nice close-up
of Carlsen he's ready to sit down for
his game here we have also a nice
close-up of Carlsen and a blurry blurry
Greece truck on the left here we have
also a nice close-up of Alexander
Grichuk pretending like he's he's not
really sure what he's going to play in
today's game but I mean who is who is he
kidding here we have this is a maybe one
of my favorite photos from this round
here you can see Chris walking across
and avoiding eye contact and you might
think I'm joking but not really some
people actually do this they will sit
down in front of their opponent and they
will avoid eye contact because until the
game ends you know the person sitting
across you is on the other side of the
board is your sworn enemy and there's no
reason to exchange any pleasantries so
once again avoiding eye contact and here
we have a nice photo great so he just
played his first move d4 feels very
happy about himself but he still didn't
hit the clock so quite quite an
interesting move and here we have Carson
in the upper left corner you can you can
check him out and as usual there is
grease shook taking a stroll chain got
some of the other games here he's
checking out the game between swiller
and Ariane hits a game actually from our
previous video and here we have actually
a nice photo of Magnus Carlsen and you
know if you don't have a trained eye you
might miss that a wild game fund
actually appeared on the right so those
of you who are me big fans of Magnus
Carlsen might totally miss a gif and
lurking in the shadows there so those
are the photos from this round now let's
check out the game we have d4 Knight to
f6 c4 and g6 and it seems that you know
you praised me about not not messing up
the sound that I forgot to do at this
game but you know I'm improving so c4 g6
the Kings Indian defense Knight to c3
and the d5 so the groom fell defense
Knight to f3 brush up to g7 and now the
immediate h4 so very nicely done by
Grisha so how do you counter this
crossing was for c6 we have Bishop to g5
crossing castles and now Bishop captures
on f6 removing the defender of the h5
square Bishop captures and now h5 so how
do you do this of course
Grichuk is very aggressive from the
start he wants to open up this h-file
you use the rook over there but he he
will not be able to Castle King side and
it's questionable if he will be able to
Castle queenside so he's definitely he
definitely prepared something we'll just
have to see what it is
Bishop to f5 so if Grichuk decides to
capture this then the two bishops will
create a very nice wall here and will
will guard the black King very nicely so
after Bishop to a5 we have III ye6 and
now he does capture H captures on g6
Bishop captures on g6 and we have Bishop
to d3 Grisha offers the exchange of the
light square Bishop Knight to d7
we have come into it to e5 now Carlsen
here is threatening efore
to win a piece so we
bushel captures on g 6h captures on g6
and now d captures on e5 Knight captures
on e5 see chapter son v5 c capture son
b5 and now rook to d1 and Carson goes
Queen to a5 now pinning this night and
since we already said that you're not
really castling kingside here
you can't Castle queenside anymore so
what do you do here you do that
definitely don't want to leave your king
garnet one so the knight will stay
pinned of course you all know the move
now here Grisha played King to f1 the
King is relatively safe on f1 there is
no light square bishop for black that
could pose any any problems and now it's
it's only a question if if Grisha can
somehow bring his Queen over here and
maybe maybe post some problems for
Carlsen so rook a to d8 night to d4 here
very shook missed an interesting idea
that is before simply getting rid of the
Queen's defense of the d5 pawn after we
move the Queen or or if Queen captures
on before then Knight captures on d5
would an attack on the Queen end and the
bishop that is undefended on f6 Queen to
d6 you have to guard the bishop and now
e4 the queen is no longer threatening
any Queen side ideas and now this Knight
has has a wonderful outpost on d5 and
after these Knights get exchanged
there's really no way to get rid of this
night from d5 so it would be a very
powerful position for Gary sugar but
okay
rook a to d8 we have night to d4 Queen
to c5 Knight to b3 here Grisha attacks
Carlson's Queen and c5 Queen to c6
we have knife to a5 now again attacking
the Queen and the b7 pawn and here we to
c7 we have Knight back to be 3x3 shook
clintus e6 and again here agree shock
repeats the position Knight to a5 we
have Queen to c7 and again for the third
time Grisha repeats the position nice
the b3 and it's cross and the move if he
repeats the position it's a draw by
three four
repetition but what's the idea why does
Grisha repeat the position with Knight
to b3 why doesn't he play rook captures
on d5 it seems like a very juicy pawn
it's a I mean it's a nice central free
point why not captured well the reason
is after rook captures you get rook
captures Knight captures and now Queen
captures on a5 of course the bishop is
undefended so Knight captures on f6 with
check King to g7 attacking the knight
and now comes knife to g4 and after
Knight captures Queen captures black is
down upon but after rook to d8 there's
really no way for white to to actually
do anything here but black is actually
even better here since the one the white
king is very awkwardly placed on f1 the
Queen can't really make any threats here
as since if the Queen ever loses the the
eye on the d1 squared and rook to d1
will be a terrible threat so here you
want to play something like g3 and first
you have to waste a couple of moves to
improve the position of your own King
but then white black will also improve
his position and black will even have
time to grab up one or two so not
something you want to look forward to as
a white
so after this Queen to see sever move
Grichuk repeated 9th to b3 and to
everyone's you know amazement or maybe
for lack of a better word cross and
repeated for the third time Queen to c6
and unmoved 23 the players kind of
agreed to a draw by threefold repetition
so as the title suggests Caixa was not
very happy with this game and the
consequences will be great as you will
see in the next round but yeah our
cousin really couldn't couldn't go for
anything here after this Knight to b3
move there's there's really no plan
Carson can hope for here even even
though the commentators said that maybe
there was a way for black to actually do
something here since the Greeks rooks
aren't connected the king is very
awkwardly placed on f1 but the engine
agrees with Carson Queen to c6 is the
strongest move Carson place it and he
agrees to a draw
so yeah that's one of the games I was
you know I had to think really hard do I
actually want to show this game do I not
want to show this game but in the end
for a certain reason I decided to show
it as well I'm sure you all know what
the reason is
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and maybe you didn't enjoy
the game so much but I hope you enjoyed
the photos as they you know that's all
part part of the game so we will see one
more game from around 11:00 and then
we're gonna talk about the standings and
and a little bit about this this round
and the tournament so far in general and
the only game we will not see from this
round is actually von Schuch vs. Gaytan
because that was the shortest game of
the tournament it was a total draw you
know it's like you open up a book and
then they you know you check out some
openings and they say here you can use
this opening and then it's a draw and
it's basically that's the game I will
even put a link to this game in the
description below if you just want to
check it out but you know we will
definitely have some photos of event you
can get fund yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and I would have to thank young
MacKinnon only young max sorry McInerney
yeah my bed
a young McInerney for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon with
one more game from around the 11 of the
2013 candidates tournament thank you
[Music]